it's my pleasure today to welcome you to
this uh
what webinar from yipsa
the Yale program for the study of
anti-Semitism my name is Jeff Alexander
and I'm professor of Sociology here at
Yale and a board member of yipsa
it's my honor and privilege as well as a
real personal pleasure to welcome my
friend and colleague Chad Goldberg to
speak today
Chad is the Martindale Boston professor
of Sociology at the University of
Wisconsin at Madison
and the author of many
articles and important books of original
research and Theory
but before telling you about some of
these I want to tell you how Chad
describes his research areas on
Wisconsin's sociology website
he describes him as
quote modern Jewish thought especially
social and political thought
the Civil incorporation of juice is an
afternoon religious minority in relation
to Modern State and nation building and
the sociology of anti-semitism
I'm reading you this because I can
assure you that it's most unusual
as far as I know Chad is the only
sociologist at a leading American
Department to describe his research
Specialties as devoted entirely to what
was once called the Jewish question
in fact Chad's first book was not about
Jews but about workers it was entitled
citizens and Powers relief rights and
race from the Freedmen's Bureau to work
fair and it won some important Awards
it was in the years after that
publication that Chad began attending to
matters concerning Jewish exclusion and
incorporation one line of which
culminated in his singular book
modernity and the Jews in Western
thoughts
it was a finalist for the National
Jewish book award and the Jordan
Schnitzer book prize and the winner of
several prizes from sociological
societies
Chad has been a fellow at some of the
world's most distinguished institutes
for advanced studies including the
Princeton Institute the vision staff's
colleague in Berlin and the MOX cyber
collagen airford
he's also been the George almasi
visiting professor at the Hebrew
University in Jerusalem
today I welcome Chad to speak at Yale
his talk as you know is entitled for
multiculturalism to anti-Semitism
revisiting the Jewish question in
America chat
Chef thank you so much uh I I want to I
want to thank you and I want to thank
Maurice for the opportunity to take part
in this webinar today Jeff I want to
thank you for that very kind
introduction uh and I want to thank all
of the attendees who are here to
participate as well it's a personal and
professional pleasure uh to be here with
all of you today I'm going to go ahead
and see if I can share my screen with
you and uh let me go ahead and get
started
uh
my uh Point of Departure uh today uh is
is Jeff's work actually uh which uh has
had a strong influence on me and uh
specifically his 2006 book The Civil
sphere
uh those of you who uh have uh read uh
this book know that nearly 90 Pages uh
of its 550 Pages
um are devoted to the Jewish question uh
as Jeff shows the Jewish question arose
uh in both Europe and America but in
these settings the instabilities of
Jewish incorporation were resolved in
markedly different ways
I can't do justice in my presentate and
my presentation today uh to
um Jeff's lengthy comparison of the
Jewish question in Europe and America
but suffice it to say that his
discussion of the Jewish question in
Europe concludes with the showa while
the corresponding discussion of the
Jewish question in America ends with the
emergence in the 1960s of a
multicultural mode of Jewish
Incorporation
the startling Resurgence of
anti-Semitism in the United States in
the last several years raises a host of
questions about the rich and insightful
discussion of the Jewish question that
we find in the Civil sphere
if American Jews have been the
beneficiaries of a multicultural mode of
incorporation since the 1960s how do we
account for the Resurgence of
anti-semitism
doesn't mean that Jeffrey Alexander's
assessment of the Jewish question in
America was overly sanguine
alternatively if the assessment was
correct for roughly half a Century
Century from the 1960s until the 2010s
does the Resurgence of anti-Semitism
indicate another shift in civil
discourse that is bringing the
Multicultural incorporation of American
Jews to an end
or is this an alarmist overreaction to
what we should instead regard as a
futile rear guard backlash and a
temporary aberration from their
Multicultural incorporation of American
Jury
while the Contemporary Resurgence of
anti-Semitism may seem to challenge
Jeff's conclusions I argue instead that
his theorization of the Multicultural
incorporation of American Jews helps to
explain the Resurgence of anti-Semitism
in two ways by highlighting the inherent
and stability of the Multicultural mode
of incorporation and by identifying new
problems of boundary definition and
identity that multiculturalism generates
if contemporary anti-Semitism is a
backlash against multiculturalist trends
that began in the 1960s then it is a
backlash that arises from the very
problems that multiculturalism of itself
produces
I will develop this thesis in four parts
first I'll briefly review the three
modes of civil incorporation uh the Jeff
has identified and the distinctive
relation of Jews to civil society that
each of those modes entails second I
will present evidence for a Resurgence
of anti-Semitism in the United States in
the past several years third I will
trace the Resurgence of anti-Semitism in
part to features of the Multicultural
mode of incorporation that Jeffrey
Alexander has identified uh fourth I
will provide additional support for this
interpretation if time permits by means
of a historical comparison to cultural
attitudes toward Jews and the calvinist
or Protestant Reform tradition
particularly among the Puritans and to
be sure the Puritans were not
multiculturalists but they did identify
themselves with Jews to a remarkable
degree and this identification created
similar problems of boundary definition
and identity which makes it I think an
instructive comparison
so Jeffrey Alexander examined the Jewish
question in relation to three ideal
typical modes by which excluded out
groups have achieved incorporation into
the Civil sphere
the first of these modes of
incorporation historically was
assimilation which entails the
separation of the person who belongs to
an out group from the stigmatized
qualities that distinguish the out group
from the core group
that separation was typically
accomplished by means of a division
between private and public life members
of primordial primordially stigmatized
groups could participate in the
discourse and institutions of civil
society and so far as they completely
shed these identities upon entering the
public domain
assimilation is inclusionary insofar as
it permits the members of our groups to
be evaluated positively and thus affords
them opportunities for civic
participation but it fails to challenge
the negative evaluation of out-group
qualities
furthermore as Jeffrey Alexander wrote
Because of its delicate and tense
balance between negatively evaluated
qualities and positively evaluated
persons assimilation is a highly
unstable mode of Incorporation
the instabilities of the assimilative
motive incorporation allow it to be
pushed backward toward exclusion or
forward toward alternative modes of
civil Incorporation
the hyphenated motive incorporation
began to emerge in the United States at
the end of the 19th century turning
immigrants and their descendants into
polish Americans Italian Americans and
so forth
hyphenation is more open to and it
Accords more positive recognition to
foreign or Outsider particularities than
does the assimilative mode of
incorporation nevertheless it remains
fraught with challenges for Jews and
other outgroups
while ethnic particularities remain
evident and pronounced and this mode of
incorporation the qualities of excluded
groups are treated as complementary but
still inferior to those of the Core
Group
Alexander concluded that the hyphenated
mode of incorporation like the
assimilative mode provides a highly
unstable basis for the expansion of
civil solidarity and therefore is liable
to be pushed backward to assimilation
and even to exclusion or else forward to
the Multicultural mode of Incorporation
the Multicultural mode of incorporation
goes further and differs markedly from
the assimilative and hyphenated modes of
incorporation because it entails the
positive evaluation of out group
qualities such as peripheral National
Origins minority racial status or
marginalized religion
these primordial qualities previously
thought to disqualify their bearers from
civil inclusion become reinterpreted as
representing variations on the sacred
qualities of Civility
following the dilemmas and failures of
the assimilative and hyphenated modes of
incorporation earlier in the 20th
century Alexander argued the
instabilities of Jewish American
incorporation were pushed in a
multicultural direction from the 1960s
onward
simply put Christian Americans began to
find Jewish qualities attractive and
themselves
Alexander's evidence for this claim was
mainly drawn from American popular
culture including a close reading of the
self-representations of Jewish cultural
producers like the author Philip Roth
and the actor and director Woody Allen
as well as demographic trends like
intermarriage
according to this interpretation
Christian Americans in the post-war era
came to to view the identity of the
previously marginalized Jewish outgroup
both as quote legitimately and
importantly different from their own and
at the same time as fundamentally the
same unquote
multiculturalism Alexander concluded
requires and helps to produce thicker
and deeper forms of mutual
identification
if American Jews begin to experience a
multicultural mode of incorporation in
the 1960s the country's erstwhile love
affair with Jewish qualities seems to
have taken a disturbing turn for the
worse in recent years
the Anti-Defamation League established
in 1913 to fight anti-Semitism and other
forms of bigotry and discrimination
monitors anti-semitic incidents in the
United States including assaults
vandalism and harassment
Indio reports indicate a steady decrease
in anti-Semitism from 2011 to 2013.
however the ADL reported a sharp rise in
anti-semitic incidents in 2014. this 21
increase from the previous year was the
first time in nearly a decade of
declines where the overall number of
incidents substantially Rose
anti-semitic incidents continue to
increase in 2015 and then surged more
than one-third in 2016 particularly
after November 2016 When Donald Trump
was elected president of the United
States
The Surge continued into the first
quarter of 2017 jumping 86 percent
during the first three months of the new
year
the number of anti-Semitic incidents in
2017 ultimately Rose to
1986 a 57 rise from the previous year
and the largest single year increase on
record and the second highest number
reported since the ADL started tracking
this data in 1979.
the number of anti-Semitic incidents in
the U.S fell slightly in 2018 before
Rising again in 2019 another
record-breaking year
Rising anti-Semitism was exemplified by
the 2017 unite the right rally in
Charlottesville Virginia where neo-nazis
chanted Jews will not Place us and the
murderous assault on the Pittsburgh Tree
of Life synagogue in 2018 which the ADL
described as the deadliest attack on the
Jewish community in the history of the
United States
the record number of anti-Semitic
incidents in 2019 included deadly
stabbings or shootings of Jews at a
rabbi's home in Muncie New York a Kosher
grocery store in Jersey City New Jersey
and a synagogue in Poway California
anti-semitic incidents declined slightly
in 2020 and then reached an all-time
high in 2021 that exceeded even the 2019
levels
and the other main organization decides
the ADL that monitors anti-semitic
incidents in the United States is the
Federal Bureau of Investigation
the FBI tracks hate crimes defined as an
action of physical violence or vandalism
whose motive is a prejudice against a
specific group and reports violence
against Jews under the category of
prejudice based on religion
the pattern of anti-jewish hate crimes
over time though lower in numbers is
roughly consistent with the pattern and
ADL data on anti-semitic incidents what
we see here in this graph is the number
of anti-jewish hate crime incidents
decreased steadily from 2011 through
2014 the trend that the ADL welcomed
however anti-jewish hate crime incidents
started to increase in 2015 rose again
in 2016 and spiked about 37 percent in
2017. after falling in 2018 anti-jewish
hate crime incidents jumped by 14 in
2019 when they comprised 13 percent of
all hate crime incidents despite Jews
constituting less than 2 percent of the
U.S population
and fell again in 2020 though they
remained higher than levels in the first
half of the decade
while data on hate climb incidents in
2021 and 2022 were not available at the
time this paper was prepared anti-jewish
hate crimes continued to seize public
attention with the armed taking of
hostages at a synagogue and Colleyville
Texas in January 2022 and the arrest
just last week of a man threatening to
kill Jewish government officials in
Michigan
the rise in anti-semitic incidents and
hate crimes is associated with a shift
and cultural attitudes toward Jews in
the United States that's what I will
argue at any rate and I think there are
worrying signs of such a shift on both
the political lefts and the political
right
on the one hand the anti-semitic motifs
of Jewish foreignness or alienness
exclusive particularism power and
wickedness parallel or correspond to
anti-zionist motifs that have appeared
in the discourse of some self-style
progressives
for example U.S representative ilhan
Omar has at various times claimed that
quote Israel has hypnotized the world
while doing evil that Congressional
support for Israel is quote All About
the Benjamins that's to say all about
money and that American supporters of
Israel quote push for allegiance to a
foreign country
although Omar is widely regarded as one
of the most Progressive members of the
U.S Congress these remarks earned her
the praise of former Ku Klux Klan Grand
wizard David Duke the reason for this is
not hard to discern Omar's rhetoric
corresponds to at least two anti-semitic
motifs one that money makes Jews
powerful and the other the Jews are more
loyal to their own interests than the
country in which they are citizens
today a segment of the American left
uses the counter-democratic code and the
discourse of Civil Society detains
American Jews who do not Embrace
anti-zionism which is according to
surveys most American Jews as bad
Americans
the shift in cultural attitudes was
strikingly displayed by The Surge of
anti-Semitism during the 2014 Israel
Gaza conflict which went beyond mere
criticism of Israel or Zionism to
include assaults on Jewish individuals
and vandalism of Jewish institutions
on the other hand under Donald Trump's
presidency from January 2017 to January
the Trump globalist spread from Far
Right anti-semitic websites into
mainstream civil and political discourse
the use of the charm as an anti-jewish
dog whistle received widespread
attention in 2018 in connection with the
resignation of Trump's chief economic
advisor Gary Cohn and the attempted
bombing of the philanthropist George
soros's home in New York
as Arya tuckman from the Anti-Defamation
League noted the application of the term
to Jews carries a host of associations
that cannot be extricated from the
history of anti-semitism
tuckman linked the term to long-running
conspiracy theories about Jewish
populations not being loyal to the
countries they live in and cooperating
through secret International alliances
the anti-globalist representation of
Jews is in some ways antithetical to the
anti-zionist representation are Jews
cosmopolitans or nationalists we might
ask nevertheless the two discourses
converge and constructing Jews as
disloyal to the United States secretive
powerful and above all anti-civil
the Multicultural incorporation of
American Jews that began in the 1960s
makes the recent Resurgence of
anti-Semitism appear surprising and
perplexing
while claims of Multicultural
incorporation seem hard to square with
evidence of rising anti-Semitism I will
argue that Alexander's theorization of
multiculturalism reveals some of the
processes that underlie this partial
reversal
since as Alexander makes clear the
Multicultural mode of incorporation does
not represent the end of an inevitable
developmental or evolutionary logic
there's no reason to expect it to remain
permanent
as Alexander conceives it
multiculturalism involves the
paradoxical perception of difference as
a variation on shared Humanity or the
perception of outgroups as legitimately
and importantly different from the core
group yet fundamentally in some sense
the same
this Paradox He suggests generates
problems of boundary definition and
identity that make the Multicultural
mode of incorporation unstable in its
own way
what Alexander means by this becomes
clear in his discussion of the
paradoxical consequences of
Multicultural incorporation for American
Jews
Christian America's Multicultural
Embrace of Jewish qualities allowed he
wrote confident assertions of Jewish
difference including a return to
traditional religious practices and
non-orthodox synagogues the growth of
Jewish Day schools and the creation of
Jewish studies departments and programs
at American universities
get Jewish assertions of difference were
accompanied by Jewish anxiety about the
continuing viability of Judaism in
America
the seemingly unwarranted anxiety was a
response to the problems of boundary
definition and identity that the
Multicultural mode of incorporation
generates and here I'm quoting Jeffrey
Alexander if difference can be
recognized only when there is increasing
solidarity between core and out group it
should not be surprising that even as
they begin to cultivate their
differences Jewish Americans would come
to feel more like non-jewish Americans
and the latter more like them
and Alexander's account it's precisely
this Mutual identification that creates
anxiety about the loss of a distinctive
Jewish identity
Rising anti-Semitism in the United
States May reflect the problems of
boundary definition and identity that
Alexander associated with
multiculturalism but in a different way
than he anticipated
if Mutual identification encourages
Jewish anxiety about the continuing
viability of Judaism in America
then it is likely to Foster an analogous
reaction among Americans with a
Christian Heritage in other words to the
extent that core group and outgroup
identities are viewed as fundamentally
the same the non-jewish core group will
also experience anxiety about the
continuing viability of its own identity
and perhaps even the national identity
with which the court Core group has been
historically closely associated
one way this anxiety finds expression is
in renewed anti-Semitism and especially
anti-semitic efforts to re-establish
hierarchical boundaries that
multiculturalism threatens to dissolve
if the Multicultural mode of
incorporation generates problems of
boundary definition and identity for the
core group as well as for American Jews
there's no reason to think that these
problems will be limited to Core group
members who are committed to one or
another political ideology
the problems May however appear in some
with different guises as a result of
these political commitments
on the one hand breaking with the
historical self-consecration of the
American Core Group some Core group
members aligned with the progressive
left are now inclined to view the core
group as a deeply anti-civil oppressor
of minorities and out groups
this transvaluation of the Core Group by
some of its own members has adverse
consequences for the Jewish out group
when Jews are perceived to be
fundamentally the same
instead of viewing American Jews as a
marginalized out group that deserves
their solidarity or allyship and
contemporary political parlance these
Core group members find it hard to
distinguish Jews from other quote
unquote powerful and privileged Core
group members
these Core group members continue to see
Israel as a little America but their
transvaluation of the American Core
group now makes this identification
polluting
rather than interpreting jewishness as a
variation on the sacred qualities of
Civility these Core group members May
instead come to see it as a variation on
the profane qualities of incivility
from there I would say it's a small step
to transfer their guilt to the Jews
their tolerance normalization or in rare
instances expression Albert expressions
of anti-Semitism I would say is the bad
conscience of the Core Group
on the other hand Core group members on
the far right try to maintain
restrictive primordial definitions of
Civility or even to make those
definitions more narrower
some of these Core group members blame
Jews for multiculturalism for
immigration and other developments that
they think threaten the American Core
Group
nevertheless they identified they
identify with Jews and surprising ways
attributing to them and ethnocentric
culture which they believe advantages
Jews and is at odds with the
multiculturalism that they believe Jews
foist on others
their hatred of Jews is and this way
conjoined With Envy
this perspective shapes attitudes toward
Israel as well
for instance in 2017 the white
nationalist Richard Spencer described
himself to an Israeli journalist as a
quote white Zionist unquote and insisted
to the journalist that quote you should
respect someone like me who understands
your identity and the experience of the
Jewish people and has analog feelings
about whites unquote
notwithstanding Spencer's spurious
analogy and distorted understanding of
Zionism these comments reveal the
ambivalence of core group members on the
far right who see Jews as a threat and
simultaneously project their own wishes
onto them
the portrait of the Jews that they offer
to the world is in fact their own
self-portrait
this theoretical argument about the
American core group and its relation to
Jews needs qualification and a few key
respects and so I want to mention those
here
uh first I don't want to suggest and I
don't mean to suggest
that the entire American Core Group
has become anti-Semitic
rather problems of boundary definition
and identity facilitate tolerance
normalization or even outright
expressions of anti-Semitism among Core
group members making such Expressions
more likely within the group
second Christianity is only one of the
primordial qualities available for
defining the American Core group and
judging civil competence
nevertheless following Alexander the
Christian qualities analytically
accentuated here because of its
particular significance of vis-a-vis the
Jewish out group
and third
while this theoretical argument is about
the core group in its relation to Jews
it raises questions about the growing
minority of Americans who are
religiously unaffiliated uh which
according to survey Research Now make up
about 29 of all Americans as well as the
very small minority of Americans who are
religiously Affiliated but belong
neither to America's historically
Christian Core Group nor to the Jewish
out group and Survey data suggests that
those Americans make up about four
percent of the population
many religiously unaffiliated Americans
belong to the Christian Core Group by
cultural heritage even if they do not
identify as Christian
they may have no use for Christianity as
church or Credo but its cultural
influence of jurors in the form of
secularized Christianity
they are therefore likely I would submit
to share and some form the anxieties
that the Multicultural mode of
incorporation generates among other Core
group members
however the anxieties of someone like
Ilan Omar would be more complicated
since Muslim Americans have arguably not
experienced a multicultural motive
incorporation their identities may be
more divided and a manner characteristic
of hyphenation or even double
consciousness
in addition the relative success of the
Multicultural incorporation of Jewish
Americans since the 1960s may lead such
minorities to resent an out group that
they perceive to have joined the core
group
in my view this is a mistaken perception
and it's mistaken I think for a few
reasons one even an ideal typical form
multiculturalism does not simply absorb
outgroups into an expanded Core Group
rather out groups are paradoxically
perceived as both legitimately and
importantly different from the core
group and is fundamentally the same
second uh the Multicultural motive
incorporation takes incomplete or uneven
forms in real civil Societies in part
because it overlaps with past modes of
incorporation that partly survive into
the present
and third and this in a way is part of
the point of this paper as a whole
renewed anti-Semitism belies the
assumption that Jews are now part of the
American Core Group in any simple uh or
straightforward sense
yeah
let me turn to the last part of my paper
here and I hope you'll indulge me with
uh this this uh excursis
the Multicultural mode of civil
incorporation is quite new in the
history of Western societies
nevertheless I think historical
analogies can still be instructive
despite the millennia-long Christian
pollution of Jews as incapable of
participating in the Civic life of
Christian societies we can find
exceptional cases in which members of a
Christian Core Group identified and
relatively thick and deep ways with the
Jewish out group
such identification usually involved a
positive evaluation of not only Jewish
persons but also some Jewish qualities
such as chosenness and biblical truth
and these instances some Christians came
to see Jewish identity as importantly
different from the core groups and at
the same time is fundamentally the same
their views anticipated multiculturalism
in this respect even if Christian
theological assumptions prevented their
views from developing fully in this
direction
cultural attitudes toward Jews and the
calvinist or Protestant reformed
tradition particularly among the
Puritans May provide the best example
puritanism always felt its inner
similarity to Judaism Max Weber wrote
even if it also felt the limits of the
similarity
consequently I will suggest Puritans
experienced problems of boundary
definition and identity similar to those
generated by multiculturalism and they
manage the resulting anxieties in ways
that eliminate the Contemporary
Resurgence of anti-Semitism in the
United States
the Protestant Reformation in the 16th
century gave rise to intense religious
conflicts and sectarian struggles among
Christians in which each faction
frequently accused the others of Judaism
for example a Bavarian Catholic preached
in a 1551 sermon that the king of
England at that time that Protestant
Edward VI his counsel and Kingdom had
all become Jews
the Church of England soon turned the
charge against its own internal
dissenters labeling Puritans as
judaizers in the late 16th century in
the association between puritanism and
Judaism was firmly in place as the 17th
century got underway
but in this instance the charge was more
than a stigmatizing label used to
discredit rivals the Puritans were
convinced that they were the true Jews
the ultimate and total Heirs of the
promises that God had made in the Hebrew
Bible
and the strong identification expressed
itself and a variety of judaizing
practices summarized by the historian
Eliana Glazer
and I'm quoting the laser here Puritans
attempted to strip away what they
regarded as corrupt layers of Episcopal
Authority and purpose ceremonialism and
reclaimed the original Apostolic
Christian faith
they Justified their position by
invoking the Bible and particularly the
Old Testament and they believed that
scripture should be read in the original
Hebrew
Puritans advocated the use of Hebrew and
biblical translation and scriptural
exegesis and identified with the
biblical chosen people
in addition many Puritans became
Scholars of post-biblical Jewish
literature such as the talmud and most
heterodox of all some even began to
adopt Jewish practices and Customs such
as the Sabbath and Passover
Puritan identification with Jews created
problems of boundary definition and
identity analogous to those that arise
in multiculturalism which fueled anxiety
about the continuing viability of their
own religious identity
the Puritans consequently tried to
reassert boundaries that had become
obscured
and this is evident for example in
conflicts over whether to readmit Jews
into England and whether to admit them
into the Massachusetts Bay Colony
the debate in 1655 to 1656 over whether
to readmit Jews into England following
their expulsion in 1290 was shaped in
part by Puritan phyto-semitism and
millenarianism
the public practices of Christian
judaizers and the growth of interest in
Hebrew had already helped to put Jews in
a favorable light among Protestant
reformers some of whom came to believe
that the return of Jews to England would
hasten the second coming of Christ
not surprisingly then some of the most
strident devotees of the mid 17th
century Puritan Revolution favored
remission of Jews
the historian Roger Healey suggests that
the readmission movement failed because
not enough English believed that the
Jews were future Christians and
harbingers of the millennium
however opposition to the readmission of
Jews also sprang from a deeper fear
namely that it would result in the
judaization of Christians and thus the
loss of a distinctive Christian identity
among religious leaders there were many
who like the Puritan pamphleteer William
pren believed that if the Jews were
readmitted the Christians quote would
sooner turn Jews than the Jews
Christians unquote
one response to this boundary crisis was
to keep Jews out of England
the symbolic logic is apparent for
example in the writings of the 17th
century political philosopher James
Harrington although Harrington advocated
a Theocratic Republic in England modeled
on the Hebrew Commonwealth established
through Moses fear of judaization led
him to oppose the readmission of Jews he
proposed instead the establishment of a
colony of Jews in Ireland where they
could be profitable to The Republic but
safely separate from it
as the sociologist Kai Erickson points
out in his classic study of deviance in
puritan New England communities maintain
their boundaries in geographical as well
as cultural space and here I'm quoting
Ericsson both of these dimensions of
group space the geographical and the
cultural set the community apart as a
special place and provide an important
point of reference for its members
and the debate over readmission of Jews
to England maintenance of geographical
boundaries served to compensate for the
obscuring of cultural boundaries
like the English Puritans their
counterparts in New England similarly
struggled to redefine boundaries that
their phytosemitism threatened to
dissolve
to be sure identification with Jews was
not the only source of boundary
definition and identity problems in the
new world but Puritan identification
which Jews threatened to obscure the
cultural boundaries of the Puritan
community in its own way and compounded
anxiety but the continuing viability of
puritanism in America
Erickson analyzed the antinomian
controversy of 1636 the Quaker
persecutions of the late 1650s and the
Witchcraft hysteria of 1692 as different
attempts by the people of the
Massachusetts Bay to clarify their
position in the world as a whole to
redefine the boundaries which set New
England apart as a new experiment and
living
the inhospitable and exclusionary
practices that New England Puritans
adopted toward the handful of Jews they
encountered in the 17th century may be
understood in the same way
are the New England Puritans persecuted
Quakers more severely than Jews
exclusion of Jews was rooted in the same
symbolic logic
uh here I'm quoting Erickson it was
exactly because the New England Puritans
shared so many features in common with
the Quakers that they had to publicize
the few crucial differences as noisily
as they could to mark off a new set of
boundaries for the New England way they
had to make a particular effort to
emphasize those points where the Puritan
and Quaker streams diverged
the New England Puritans treatment of
the Jews they encountered events an
analogous effort to mark off boundaries
and keep a group with whom they shared
many features safely separate
so in some Puritans were not
multiculturalists but they did identify
with Jews to an unusual degree and this
identification generated problems of
boundary definition and identity similar
to those that arise from the
Multicultural motive Incorporation
consequently the Puritans experienced
anxiety about the continuing viability
of their religious movement and the loss
of their own distinctive religious
identity if they saw Jews as future
Christians they also worried that they
themselves might become Jews the closer
their identification would choose the
more they found it necessary to keep
Jews at arm's length
as the boundaries that set puritanism
apart threatened to become more obscure
they strove to mark off a new set of
boundaries by excluding Jews from the
geographical or cultural space that the
community occupied
and this history I would submit Finds
Its parallel and contemporary fears that
Jewish zionists and globalists are
figuratively judaizing America and in
anti-semitic efforts to exclude Jews
from the Civil sphere
to conclude while there is persuasive
evidence of a shift beginning in the
1960s toward a multicultural mode of
incorporation for American Jews the
Resurgence of anti-Semitism in recent
years in the form of a Sharp rise in
anti-semitic incidents as well as
changing patterns of discourse and
cultural representation underscores the
instability of this mode of
Incorporation
after a half century of Multicultural
incorporation of American Jews how and
why is anti-Semitism now on the rise
a theory that posits the Multicultural
incorporation of American Jews would
seem to have difficulty explaining the
Revival of anti-semitism
but in fact Jeffrey Alexander's analysis
of multiculturalism provides important
clues for understanding its partial
reversal
his analysis his analysis acknowledged
the instability of the Multicultural
motive incorporation and traced it to
the new problems of boundary definition
and identity that multiculturalism
generates
according to Alexander these problems
explained why American Jews felt anxiety
about the continuing viability of
Judaism in America despite an
unparalleled Embrace of Jewish qualities
by the Christian Core Group
what I've argued here today is that
these problems of boundary definition
and identity also generate corresponding
anxieties among members of the Christian
Core group and these anxieties are
contributing to the Resurgence of
anti-Semitism in the United States today
thanks very much
oh thank you very much Chad I'm I'm not
able to get myself on the screen at this
point but you can hear me right yes
there we go and um
I will uh
I will answer to them I will ask them
for you to chat
um
well one question that might be helpful
to answer is
um
by David freund what is he asked what is
boundary definition
yeah so
uh
I mean I am
um drawing here on uh Jeff's work but
also in the work of Kai Erickson
um and some others all of whom sort of
emphasized the importance of two groups
and communities of having uh clear
boundaries uh that that set the
identities of those groups apart that
distinguish them in some way
um and um allow the members of those
groups to
um to consecrate uh their their
identities their ways of life their
practices as somehow special distinctive
um and
um uh and and and and worthy of
difference so I I guess the uh what I
would say then is that the boundary
definition has to do with how
um any Community any any uh cultural
group uh distinguishes itself from
others um how it uh defines itself and
any process of self-definition is going
to involve a process of Distinction that
it's going to uh in some way set itself
apart from others not necessarily I
think in an Insidious way and I don't
think uh that this kind of boundary work
is inherently bad or
um uh or uh or or detrimental to to
other groups uh I think it's just part
of um how identity formation works so
that's what I have in mind when I talk
about boundary definition I hope that
makes it a little bit clearer
yes that's that's important for
non-sociologists to get some of the the
terms out there
um here's another question for you from
Rena Seltzer she asked how does the Welk
ideology which promotes anti-semitism
by defining Jews as privileged
oppressors
and through intersectionality defining
Zionism
and Israel as colonialists how does this
woke ideology fit into your schema
yeah so I you know I I think there's a
lot of debates about
um This this term and what it means and
uh
um people use it in different ways some
people use it very broadly some people
use it and uh sort of more more specific
ways
um
I you know I think I touched on this uh
when I talked about uh members of uh
again not all members of the core group
but some members of the core group uh
who have
um
uh who who have been involved and what
we could describe as a trans valuation
of the quote group itself so again the
point that I tried to make and maybe I
went through this a little bit too
quickly maybe it was lost is that what
to me is a really interesting process uh
sociologically and culturally is that
you have
uh people that are I think members of
the core group not exclusively but some
of them are Core group members or uh
have that cultural heritage who um who
have uh come to regard the core group uh
that they belong to uh as deeply
anti-civil uh and so uh what I suggested
is that this is my argument is less
about the ideology so I think the roots
of anti-Semitism lie Less in ideology
than in these new problems of um
boundary definition and identity uh This
this term that I borrowed from Jeff's
work in his and civil sphere Theory uh
which are which are really sort of
cultural and structural uh uh problems
generated by the Multicultural mode of
incorporation so so my argument is not
really about the effects of ideology I
think maybe the way that ideology
political ideologies come into play here
is that they mediate and they shape how
members of the core group
um make sense of these anxieties and how
they
um respond to these anxieties and so
there I think we see some variation and
uh uh but I I don't think that
anti-semitism
uh is a product of um
uh
one and only one political ideology I
think there's there's a variety of
ideologies that we can find in the
American political landscape today and
I'm struck and and and and and worried
by uh what I see as Expressions that
made to semitism or at least tolerance
of into semitism uh on different sides
of uh the political divide in the
political Spectrum so uh so I this is so
there is there is a connection but uh I
wouldn't say and I I don't argue in this
paper that uh a political ideology woke
or otherwise is the source of these
problems
yeah
thank you now we have a question kind of
from the opposite side
um
this is anonymous
um he he says why is an anti-Semitism
historically has been correlated with
wises in income inequality and social
unrest
given the extreme income inequality in
America today do you think this play is
or has played a role in the rise of
anti-semitism
yeah interesting
um
I I think so I think the roots of
anti-Semitism are multiple and complex
um
I think that there there can be a
conjunction of different factors at work
uh and I think the the
um
the globalist language that I talked
about is maybe a way in which uh anxiety
is about uh growing economic inequality
um get linked to antipathy or hostility
toward Jews
um
so this this is a long-standing feature
of anti-Semitism when you when you look
at this uh Jews have been uh blamed uh
or associated with uh the power of
Finance with the power of money
um uh uh you see this also I mentioned
in the talk uh the way that um
this comes out uh in uh in in some uh
anti-zionist tropes uh where again this
is the power of money is uh emphasized
and I provided some examples of that uh
and so so this sort of parallels of
corresponds to uh how these tropes have
been
um uh used in relation in relationship
to Jews directly
um
so I I think it is a factor I think it's
a contributing factor I think it's uh
linked with the factors that I
emphasized or that I focused on and and
complicated ways but uh I do think uh
it's it is part of uh what's going on
the interesting question to me is
um you know economic inequality has been
growing for decades uh and
um
yet anti-Semitism was on the decline uh
until much more recently and so if you
would say well anti-Semitism is
basically a response to Growing economic
inequality what then explains the timing
why uh why is it so delayed given that
these qualities have been um deepening
uh for for many years so that's why I
think uh by itself this is not really a
sufficient explanation but I also it
seems to me that it would have to be uh
it would have to be taken into
consideration for any kind of
comprehensive account of anti-Semitism
today
great this is a very good series of
exchanges now um I'm gonna speak
for Maury Samuels question after
complimenting you for a great talk quote
he asked this
my question is how you account for the
fact that anti-Semitism is rising
globally
including in countries like France which
have not followed the same pattern of
multiculturals as in the US yeah
interesting yeah
so this is so the argument that I
develop here specifically about the U.S
and uh
I think that's a good question I I think
we need more you know I I am sort of a
comparative as well as a historical
sociologist and so I think we need uh
sort of more comparative research
because I agree with Mari that this is
something that we see in many countries
around the world
um and uh what it suggests to me uh is
that
um again that there are multiple factors
at work
um I'm reminded here of William
brustein's book
um the roots of hate uh which uh uh
really try to get at these sort of
multiple manifestations of anti-Semitism
and the uh the the different forms that
it took in the the different uh the the
different uh sources of anti-Semitism
um that sometimes come together
um
I think uh in the European context
I I yeah I don't know how far I want to
go in so I guess two things I want to
say about this maybe I you know I
hesitate to say too much because I
haven't this is a a question that I'm
not sure about the answer and I think
this requires more research so I
hesitate to to say too much but
um I I want to say two things first of
all I I forgot to mention this uh at the
beginning of my talk this paper I want
to say
um is part I should have mentioned this
before it's part of a symposium that's
forthcoming in the American Journal of
cultural sociology uh and uh those
papers I think provide some of this
comparative framing that you don't get
in this paper alone so my paper is uh
focused on the US in particular uh
there's another paper uh that Jeff and
Tracy Adams contributed to that
Symposium uh which is really comparative
uh in nature and tries to develop a kind
of fearization about uh comparative
variations that we see in expressions of
anti-Semitism uh and I I think does it
really insightfully actually uh in a way
that's both historical and comparative
uh and then the third set in those
the third um uh uh paper there uh deals
with the Scandinavian countries so you
you get a kind of cross-national
perspective on anti-semitism
and the other thing that I was going to
say is I I don't know uh
how widespread this view is but I am
struck by the perspective of some
european-born intellectuals uh I'm
thinking of people like Alan Badu
um Maddie bunzo and Enzo Traverso who
have insisted that Jews are now part of
the core group
um that after uh the showa Jews became
privileged insiders uh in European
societies in Western Europe uh
privileged insiders have a dominant
Judea Christian uh European or Western
order at the expense of new out groups
particularly Muslims I'm quite skeptical
of that argument myself
um but uh I think that if I were going
to explore uh the roots of
um
anti-Semitism in countries like France
and other European countries I would
want to make this part of the analysis
uh I would want to try to understand to
what extent this view is widely held uh
and uh to what extent this view
contributes to images of Jews as
in the current uh political conjunction
uh reactionary and anti-civil uh so this
would be something I would want to
explore further I think but I don't have
a very good answer to your question mark
because I haven't done the comparative
work myself
okay that this is a question uh from
that kind of relates to to this
discussion from Diane Louie
does the anxiety regarding boundary
definition presuppose that the excluded
group
retains inferiority in the mind of the
Core Group
that is is there a pervasive stigma in
the core group in being perceived as
having intersectionality with the
excluded group
Jeff can you read that one more time I'm
not sure I fully understood that
question I I don't think that I don't
understand this last sentence but let me
just repeat the first sentence because I
do think you can and address that does
the anxiety regarding boundary
definitions
presuppose that the excluded group
retains inferiority in the mind of the
Core Group
in other words I think they mean as it's
being Incorporated like you had just
talked about
yeah yeah
um
I wouldn't put it that way I wouldn't
put it that way I you know because I
think what is um what is distinctive
about the Multicultural mode of
incorporation as I understand it uh is
um that those those uh out group
qualities that were proceeded
stigmatizing the past
um become increasingly destigmatized uh
and even admired
um I think uh what that does
um uh it does fuel anxieties about
um
uh identity and
um boundaries and sort of definitions of
of sort of the core group uh and among
some Core group members I think that
leads to an effort to reassert
hierarchical boundaries that
multiculturalism tends to dissolve uh so
I I would put it a little bit
differently I I I think this is not
quite uh how I would understand things
okay I'm gonna now uh translate a
question from uh yada de Leon
could you expand on how other out group
communities other art group communities
especially black American communities
contribute to and or push back against
this Resurgence of anti-semitism
I'm especially interested in hearing
more about the resentment aspect that
you'd mentioned yeah
yeah also an interesting question uh
you know again here I can be only
tentative you know I haven't done I
haven't done the work you know the
research that you know would allow me to
to speak uh really authoritatively about
this I I my my sense my impression is
um that within uh other outgroup
communities
um
there is sometimes uh probably a feeling
of resentment uh to other out groups
that are perceived to be more successful
uh and
um
but I think that I I don't think that
that it would be fair to say that that
uh sort of is the be-all and all of um
attitudes and those other communities
there's also uh the possibility and
sometimes the realization of uh
solidarity uh among uh those out groups
even those even when those ad groups
have sort of different uh relative
degrees uh of of sort of um successful
Multicultural uh Incorporation
and I'm thinking in particular
[Music]
um
I think in particular of an incident
that happened on my own campus several
years ago uh there was an anti-semitic
incident on campus
there was a kind of uh sort of a
teaching that was held about it
and I remember uh the teaching was
attended by lots of students some of
them were Jewish some of them uh were
non-jewish and some of them were
African-American
and uh
initially the discussion sort of uh
started to fall into this groove that
you sometimes see in these these kinds
of conversations about sort of uh who
has suffered more historically and I
think his discussions are always uh
kind of pointless I don't think they
really ever serve anybody well
um uh also I I don't know how you would
sort of quantify degrees of suffering
uh and uh so it sort of went in that
direction initially but by the end of
the evening
um
I was struck that
[Music]
um
some of the same people who had sort of
begun this way had moved to a different
way of talking and had begun to identify
with each other in a way that they I
think maybe didn't at the beginning of
the evening uh and had begun to sort of
uh Identify some commonalities in their
experiences so their experiences were by
no means identical I don't want to
suggest that they are uh but um they
began to see some some commonalities uh
and and they began to see each other not
as sort of competitors uh uh in terms of
um you know claiming the title of of
who's who's uh uh who has been most
wronged historically uh but as as people
who um shared not identical conditions
not identical situations but situations
with enough elements shared in common
um that they could begin to perceive a
way of working together
um to move the campus and a more
inclusive Direction and to work together
to do that uh and uh I'd like to think
uh that is still possible I do think
that it's still possible
um though I think for a variety of
reasons uh there's there's many forces
that work in American society today that
make that that hard and difficult uh but
uh this this too I think uh remains a
real possibility that is sometimes
realized in practice in American society
okay here are two more
I would say specific questions
um
from Laz Schneider first to what extent
are anti-semitic incidents related to
Islamic issues especially regarding in
relationship to Israel or otherwise for
example
Omar to what
can the increased black anti-Semitism be
attributed
okay
I mean again an interesting question so
my focus has been on on the core group
on the American Core group and so this
is really a question about groups
outside of the core
um
this in a way I think relates to mari's
question uh about France so you know so
if the question is about
um
anti-Semitism within Muslim communities
in the United States
um I have no doubt that it exists uh but
I think this is a much less of a problem
in the United States than it is in a
place like France uh because uh Muslims
as a percentage of the population in the
United States is a much lower percentage
of the population in the U.S than it is
in France uh so uh I don't see Muslims
as the sort of primary source of
um of of anti-Semitism uh and and this
country uh I I for one thing there's not
enough of them in order for them to play
this role uh and uh so so uh this is
what I would say about the Islamic
issues
um
you know in terms of sort of Muslims and
and blacks you know again we're talking
about other out groups uh and here I you
know the I I can simply uh repeat what I
said in the paper uh about this
um that I I think um we have to
distinguish the sources when
anti-Semitism does arise uh uh within
other out groups we have to distinguish
uh the factors that work the Dynamics
there from the core group because I
think the Dynamics are different uh and
uh I think uh sometimes uh there is a
kind of a politics of resentment that is
at work here uh but I also think uh
that um
an analysis of
the degree to which anti-Semitism exists
in these communities also has to take
into consideration
um
the the the way in which the
Multicultural incorporation of these
groups uh has been less successful uh
and
um this is uh yeah I'll just leave it
there for now
thank you
um
here is a another specific question I
think we're beginning to wrap up
uh what is this this what is the
relationship between anti-Semitism and
anti-israel sentiments
I.E the critical view of what the state
of Israel has been doing to Arabs
to me it seems paradoxical that
alt-right figures like Trump are somehow
supportive of the Israeli government
while instigating anti-semitic
sentiments themselves yeah
yeah another great question I um
you know I would make a distinction uh I
want to make a distinction between
criticism of Israel
and right now uh I I think uh and I'm
speaking you know just uh personally not
as a you know this is not a sociological
uh uh statement this is a this is a
personal statement right now I think uh
there's a lot to criticize in the
current government uh and Israel
um I would I would distinguish that uh
from anti-zionism
uh and uh anti-zionism I would think of
as a kind of um as yet another kind of
political ideology uh in which
um
uh
uh the existence of a Jewish National
homeland in Palestine is considered uh
illegitimate that it was illegitimate
from the beginning remains illegitimate
uh and uh so so this is this is a
different I think uh different kind of
thing
um
I uh am certainly not somebody who
thinks the criticism of Israel is uh
inherently or by definition uh
anti-semitic
um
I would I don't even think that
anti-zionism
uh is inherently anti-semitic although I
think there's a lot of overlap between
anti-zionism uh and anti-Semitism today
and the way that I tend to think about
this uh is a way that um
uh here I'm influenced by Mitchell Cohen
who wrote a piece in 2003 along these
lines who talked about the ways that um
anti-zionist discourses ways of talking
ways of thinking
um position Zionist or Israel's or
Israel and ways analogous to how
anti-Semitism positions Jews and that I
actually think uh Cohen was onto
something I think there's a lot of
evidence for that uh and um uh that's
what I tried to suggest uh in the paper
as well
okay I'm going to ask you relay two more
questions and then we'll call it a day
um
by David silverberg it's a pretty long
question but I think it's an interesting
one he says he's piggybacking off a
previous answer about Jewish
incorporation into the dominant group
I love uh
Etc he says I have a question about
where the reassertion of whiteness
as the primary defining sociological
frame
in the United States fits in this seems
important because
one whiteness in the US is obviously
unstable there's a ton of work on the
incorporation of different ethnic groups
across disciplines and two because unite
the right event raised in this
presentation clearly is also not just
towards Jews
but uh but to many other groups based on
whiteness
um
so how are you factoring or not
factoring in whiteness as an in-group
identity yeah
yeah I I have sort of bracketed the
question in this paper uh so
um you know and I think really
addressing this uh in the detail and
depth that it that uh it needs to be
would require a paper of its own uh and
there's a lot being written about this I
um
I agree with the points about whiteness
being something uh unstable uh the
boundaries of whiteness have we know
have been contested and shifted over
time historically yeah
um
there is
so so we we know that I would also say
that
um whiteness is another one of these
sort of primordial qualities by which
the American Core group has historically
been defined
and the relationship of Jews to
whiteness uh is uh sort of interesting
one uh Eric Goldstein and others have
written about this uh very perceptively
um I think this would have to be part of
a wider conversation about uh
about Core group and its relationship to
outgroups in American history
uh but maybe the last thing I will say
about this is that
um
one of the things that uh sometimes
bothers me about these these sort of
discussions about Jews and whiteness
is uh I have
I have the feeling sometimes that these
discussions become they start to revolve
around the question of whether Jews are
white uh where the Jews uh have ever
been white when do they become whites
are they still white who has the
authority to Define Jews racially uh and
uh those are interesting questions
but what I worry about I guess is that
um
in a way uh the
the
I have a feeling that these discussions
sometimes in a kind of procrustian
fashion try to squeeze Jews into other
categories and I'm always struck by the
fact uh that anti-Semitism uh is
something that Jews can suffer from and
be victimized by
um regardless of the racial status of
whether they're sort of perceived and
defined as as white or not uh and I
think this is sometimes gets lost in
these discussions it's sort of it sort
of Falls by the wayside uh when uh the
discussion comes uh starts to to be
focused exclusively on um
on color uh and uh well if we had more
time you know I would I would invoke
some things that that Du Bois wrote late
in his life in his career uh about the
Jewish question uh where he sort of
acknowledged that early in his career he
tended to think of uh race racism racial
conflict exclusively in terms of color
uh and later came to see that it was a
more multifaceted and more complicated
kind of social phenomenon uh and uh I
tend to agree with Du Bois uh on on this
point
um I think those kinds of things get
sometimes get lost not necessarily but
sometimes get lost uh when um the
conversation shifts to questions about
whiteness and the relationship of Jews
to whiteness
thanks
um I'm gonna ask you the last question
then add on
something from me which relates to that
Michael all Nick asks do trance an
anti-semitic incidents
and hate crimes necessarily index trans
in anti-Semitism
among the general American population
and I think that's a good question and I
want I was thinking that
whether the
uh
the indexing you shall be the disturbing
index and we're all aware of it of
anti-Semitic incidents and hate crimes
and
I think you know this from my own paper
in our Symposium but is this to indicate
an increase in anti-semitic beliefs
or an increase in public
anti-semitic actions
in other words it kind of
disinhibition
of
[Music]
which doesn't mean that there's an
increase of anti-Semitic beliefs I don't
want to you know um
block out the first question I think
they're they're related to each other
yeah
yeah um well first I'll just say uh
hello to Michael Michael is a friend and
colleague so uh it's it's great that
you're able to to be here Michael
um so I I focused on incidents
um for a couple of reasons
um the you know data on incidents are
are readily available uh there are sort
of organizations that are collecting
this data uh and
um
uh number one uh number two
I'm enough of a pragmatist to think that
um
beliefs that uh that don't have
practical consequences uh are are are
are perhaps less interesting uh and uh
so
um
and and I think that's I think I think
that's sort of a sort of a a view that
many people would hold so of course
we're concerned about anti-semitic
beliefs but uh we're most concerned
about those beliefs uh when they're when
they find expression and anti-semitic uh
action or antisemitic practices
um
the question of whether these incidents
uh
indicates a growth and beliefs or uh
simply uh a weakening of the
prohibitions against acting on those
beliefs or expressing those beliefs is
an interesting one
um I don't know the answer to that
question
um and I think the data that I have here
that I used in this paper and that I
presented this paper doesn't allow us to
answer that question I I think uh the
ADL
and some other Jewish groups are trying
to
um get at the belief question more
directly with survey data uh and um
the problem with that is uh
if you you want to see how these beliefs
sort of change over time you you need to
kind of longitudinal study right so it's
not enough to have a snapshot of
um what the beliefs are this year it
doesn't tell us much if we don't know
what the beliefs were what they looked
like five years ago or ten years ago or
25 years ago and I'm not sure there's
really good longitudinal data about that
maybe there is I'm but I I'm not sure
that there is uh so I think it's an
important question it's a question that
I'll say that I don't know the answer to
and
um and I think it requires more research
thank you
Chad this is I want to thank you for uh
this very stimulating paper about a
subject that is
immensely depressing but your talk was
not depressing but inspiring and your
open-minded response to the questions
um has been just great so
thank you very much on behalf of this
community and
we look forward to describe your work in
the future thanks so much
okay bye everybody